vous avez été là pour nous hier nous
sommes là pour vous aujourd'hui c'est
par ce slogan que la boîte de nuit le
mistral à aix en provence a ouvert ses
portes aux étudiants ce mercredi lancé
par le collectif des discothèques de la
région provence alpes côte d'azur et de
corse cet événement est une initiative
pour venir en aide aux jeunes qui
souffrent eux aussi des la crise
sanitaire
objectif distribuer des paniers repas
gratuit seule condition être détenteur
d'une carte d'étudiant
des étudiants sont nos promos nos
principaux clients
donc on a trouvé ça normal et on le fait
vraiment de mon coeur de avec nos moyens
d'essayer de la rendre service si on
peut leur apporter un petit quelque
chose en plus c'est vraiment très
important et ça nous fait très plaisir
outre les denrées alimentaires les
élèves ont également pu profiter des
services de praticiens de santi
également bénévole donc ils sont proposé
de venir s'ils peuvent soutenir aider il
ya des chauffards aux log
il y à des psychologues il ya des
thérapeutes
il ya des ostéopathes tout ça
bénévolement pour pouvoir un donner un
petit coup de pouce et mettre leur
pierre à l'édifice
une première opération avait déjà attiré
près de 150 étudiants
je suis vraiment reconnaissant d'être
ici franchement c'est un très bonne idée
parce que
il ya beaucoup étudiante qui ne qui ne
connais pas du tout cette association
existe donc c'est cette importance est
vraiment essentiel pour nous en fait
c'est surtout super c'est gratuit parce
que nous les étudiants financièrement
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué et c'est
vrai que j'ai compris du pays sept
séances d'ostéopathie que toutes nos
angoisses pourrait se répercuter sur le
fonctionnement de notre corps donc il
fallait simplement c'était une évidence
fallait que j'aille l'accueil positif
des étudiants à même le mistral et ses
bénévoles à réitérer cette opération
le collectif souhaite désormais proposer
cet événement au moins deux fois par
mois